the Joe Rogan experience there's
something about walking around barefoot
that seems really [ __ ] gross I love
it in the summer it's the first thing I
want to just get my shoes off yeah oh
yeah I climb up the mountains barefoot
until I get to where the rocks are you
know anyway oh yeah I've walked like the
60 miles from the road to my camp
two-thirds of the way barefoot really
yeah got a blister on my foot after
about 20 miles and took my shoe off and
I realized hey the foot without a shoe
feels a lot better than one with a shoe
so I took them both off when the rest of
the way oh yeah I'm big into walking
barefoot but you got like soft pack
ground up there right
the ground sponge if it's damp if it
dries out then those lichens get
abrasive then it's hard to go barefoot
they get very abrasive but if they're
damp man they're soft you can use them
for toilet paper believe me I do use
lichens for toilet paper I've used all
the different stuff for toilet paper but
lichens are one of the best mmm if
they're moist if they're dry they're
good for firestarter that's about it so
that Lake where you live you live right
off you fish in that Lake a lot they're
been years I fished there like I said
there was one year when I never went out
I stayed for 15 months and I fished a
lot that summer you know Park I like 75
fish or something that summer if I
remember right but I don't eat a lot of
fish I'm not a big fish eater
and all right a weasel those desperate
times
Oh neat one out the lake right hey
there's my camp oh that's so pretty man
Wow look where you live well lived I
don't live there all the time like right
um this the other thing is the
situation's change with my permits and
you can't get a permit to live there and
I can't even get a permit to make TV
there now I'm a TV show anymore really
yeah I can transition I'm not making TV
so right now I'm in the process of
losing my permit for commercial use I
have a trapping cabin permit but
honestly I'm not interested in trapping
I did some trapping when I first went
out there but it's not something that
I'm gonna do to you know sell fur and
make money and that's what that permits
for so I'm probably going to be given
that up
so but so so you're not allowed to even
keep that cabin up there if that cat was
the case I had to take it down really
yeah I had to take that cabin down right
now I have a tent up there because that
cabin was illegal when they gave me my
permits just last year I had to remove
the illegal cabin and then I had a
permit to build a new cabin with my
friends in the new cabin in the old
cabin the new cabin was going to be
legal because it had a permit they can't
give you a permit for any illegal cabin
but they so they can't give you a permit
for cabin okay they're bureaucrats why
don't you tell them listen come back
tomorrow want to take this apart and put
it back together again exactly the same
way so tomorrow when you come back it'll
be the new cabin exactly this is the old
cabin it was time for an upgrade I go
I've got four kids now Joe
that place is 100 square feet hmm so I
was kind of excited about building new
cabin but yeah that 200 square foot mom
all right
something huge I think it's the 400 they
said I could go up to 400 so they said
yeah but uh how big is adds of the room
right now I we all we live in a what is
this this room is bigger than 400 feet
Wow
so you living in something smaller than
this whole room right now we live in a
600 square foot cabin whoa in Fairbanks
yeah exactly
that's huge for me we lived in a 200
square foot one until just well I think
it was like a year ago
so you living in the place where you
built when you bought the piece of land
yeah except I've expanded over the years
I started off with one acre and then as
I could afford it I bought up my
neighbors I got six acres and three
cabins now oh nice
[Applause]